welcome back to Las Vegas now with over
500 miles of shoreline Lake Mead is a
boaters paradise in the perfect place to
spend a long summer day looking for some
summer fun how about hitting the lake
you don't have a boat no problem you can
rent one I'm here with Bruce Nelson
Bruce I do buddy good how are you I am
awesome I'm on a boat can we rent this
pontoon boat yeah you can rent this one
right here
we ran out we reserve them for full days
boating lake need calm take your whole
family out a good time hit the water
like me this is a beautiful pontoon boat
this way you said it's perfect for
families the top is back for the top
comes down for some shade yeah I got
some shape we got the top back right now
but this shade comes over so if you
don't like the Sun all the time you got
a half shade half no shade and go out
and have a good time how fast can a boat
like this go this one's not very fast
this one's going to do like 15 miles an
hour but you go out relax have a good
time it's just it's about the float not
the boat you're just going on have a
good look all right we have some other
building options can you show us yeah
absolutely
what is this you option number two I
think your friends and family out I'm
going on our speedboat boats gonna go
faster a few less people and go on it
but you can go tubing you can go knee
boarding you just go cruising at a
higher speed and go have a really good
time on the water
I noticed behind me there are some wave
runners behind me absolutely yeah good
wave runners you can go out will you
plus one person and go rip across the
lake have a good time I do have my
lifejacket on could we give those a test
run yeah your legal let's go all right
let's do it
so this is one of the wave runners that
we could run out here like me yep you're
ready all right send me out buddies all
right
I started out the green button right
it's a green button it's on yeah so JC's
on our one of our wave runners we're I
don't like out of the marina it's a
no-wake zone right here so in this area
you can't go any faster than five miles
an hour or weightless speed and once we
hit the the no-wake buoys then he can
open it up and go go as fast as ski and
he's comfortable going with his safety
factor
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought
[Music]
to make sure everything was on point you
know what else day see the gun show okay
what is your secret I didn't push up
before I went out I just had I didn't
push this for an hour I'm like I'm gonna
be on camera and a t-shirt I got to do
push-ups Wow well that was really cool
it was so much fun I guess I meant to be
on yeah seriously if you want to rent a
boat you go to visit boating lake mead
calm they got boats and everything it
was a blast out there it was so much fun
I could spend all day out there really
you didn't look like you were having fun
at all yeah write down the board huh
yeah definitely I